so typically the the shaman engages in
practices that are
putting uh significant changes in uh
their attention
as we mentioned there's often
significant disruptive strategies
sleep deprivation sex deprivation social
isolation the use of psychedelics
extended chanting all of these dancing
all of these things are designed to
bring about radical changes in the way
in which the brain
is operating now
part of what a shaman is doing is i
would argue also getting into
the flow state so
the flow state has become something that
discussed both academically and in the
popular culture
it was made famous uh in work uh by
chick sent me high
his book flow the flow experience
brought it to the forefront in 1990. so
what is the flow experience
um so the flow experience is
experience people get into they often
describe it as like being in the zone
so you are involved in a task that is
very
demanding in fact it has a particular
structure to it
so these are your
skills and these is how demanding the
situation is
right and the flow state is one in which
the demands of the situation
just slightly go beyond your skill
abilities
right and so you can get what's called
here
shakespeare often represents this by the
flow channel
when my skills can just through we'll
talk about this through like sort of
insight and restructuring when i can
just enough
exact and extend my skills to meet the
demands so i have to put everything i've
got into it
then i get into the flow channel if my
skills exceed the demands i fall into
boredom
if my demands exceed the skills
all right i fall into anxiety now of
course the thing about you is
you're very good at learning in
situation so you need a kind of context
in which your skills as your skills
improve
your environment also improves so
one of the things we've created in our
culture if we have created uh
flow induction machines um
because what what those machines have
are
a situation where your skills are
constantly improving and the
demands of the environment are
constantly improving and these skill
induction
these sort of these flow induction
machines have other properties
that are very important in them there's
a very tight feedback between what you
do and how the environment responds
you're getting very clear information
and
failure matters it's like at least
symbolically because you can die
and of course some of you are probably
realizing that i'm talking about video
games
uh video games are one of the most
reliable ways of inducing the flow state
in people
in fact part of the reasons why video
games are addictive and they now being
considered to be a bona fide addiction
by the world health organization
is precisely because they engender the
flow state
addictions we'll talk about this later
when we talk about addictions addictions
run off machinery that is evolutionarily
adaptive
that's why it's compelling so
the flow state what are other things
that people do to get into the flow
state they play jazz
they do martial arts i'm a martial
artist right
one that's particularly interesting
because there's no other explanation for
why people do it
other than they get into the flow state
is rock climbing
because rock climbing otherwise would
like it's it's like
some sort of torture from greek
mythology right you presented like
here's a rock face
what i want you to do is i want you to
go up that it's going to be really
physically demanding it's going to hurt
you
you might fall to you and harm yourself
and once you get to the top you come
back down
it would seem like a torturous thing to
do well we know why people
rock climb they rock climb because they
get into the flow state
and the flow state is deeply deeply
positive for people
it's not the same thing as physical
pleasure
right in fact the flow state is much
more connected to meaning in life
in fact the more often you get into the
flow state
the more likely you will rate your your
life as meaningful
the more the more you will experience
well-being
now what's interesting also about the
flow state and remember we're doing this
because
i'm talking about that shamanism is
probably a practice for practicing
getting into the flow state so remember
that
right the thing about the flow state
it's a universal
people across cultures socioeconomic
groups
genders language environments
age groups report being able to get into
the flow state
and they describe it in detail almost
exactly the same way
that's a universal and universals are
important in cognitive science
you pay attention to the universals
because they give you profound insight
into the machinery
what's it like to be in the flow state
well when you're in the flow state right
you feel like you're deeply at one with
things
so for example i'm a martial artist and
when i'm sparring it's like
my sense of connectedness to my opponent
is
really enhanced and i'm really at one
and that comes with it this kind of
spontaneity so when it when when when i
was
when a strike is coming to my hand is
just that i don't
sort of raise your hand now john
it flows out of me hence the word right
and the block is there
the hockey player the goalie just puts
out his hand
the glove hand and the puck is there
there's this tremendous sense of at one
minute
and then closely allied to it is this
right
at one level you know like the shaman
dancing or chanting that there's
tremendous
metabolic energy at work effort you're
making
at one level all this effort
but at another level it feels effortless
that's the spontaneity again it just
seems to flow
from you your sense of time is passing
differently
your sense of self is being dramatically
altered
so when people are in the flow state
right their self a kind of
self-consciousness
disappears that that self-conscious you
know we carry around that
self-consciousness
that that's always doing this this sort
of thing it's constantly sort of
doing our autobiography how's my day
going how am i doing who am i what am i
doing blah blah
and it's also checking how do i image
management how do i look what are people
think of me how am i doing am i under
threat
all of that nuttering and oh am i
failing i was i knew
and that of course and that can get out
of hand and
like when you're in depression you
ruminate on all that stuff and it
overwhelms you
but we all carry that burden around it's
taxing and the thing in the flow state
it's gone because there's no space for
all of that
because you're so right engrossed
in the task the other thing about the
flow state
is it's super salient like it's like
it's like like it's like the kind of
brightness and vividness you get in a
video game
the world seems more intense
and people really like this experience
and not only do they like it
it seems to be where they do their best
work so the flow experience is an
optimal experience
in two ways many people regard it as the
best
experiences they can have
but it's also where they're doing their
very best at what they want to
excel in that's why
it's so motivating to get into the flow
state
so
why is the flow state so good
so this year 2018 i've
published some work with adrian hara
bennett and leo ferraro
in which we tried to argue for
what the cognitive mechanisms are in the
flow state see chick sent my high
tells you the environmental conditions
what you need in order to get into
the flow state you need skills
and demand to be matched
you need there to be very tight coupling
between you
and the environment like in the video
game you need very clear information it
can't be ambiguous or vague
and failure has to matter it has to be
costly to you in some fashion
specified all of that you also specified
the kind of training that helps enhance
you get
to get you into the flow state
and think about this think about what i
said
last time and we're going to explore
this more training and mindfulness the
more people have training and
mindfulness
increases their capacity to get into the
flow state
now can we come up with a unified
explanation for all of this i think we
can
both for the phenomenology why we're
experiencing what we're experiencing
when we're in the flow state and why is
it improving your cognition
and therefore why would the shaman
be enhancing their cognition by getting
into something like the flow state
through their ritual practices
okay so think about the rock climber
okay
the rock climber is climbing
remember we talked about how you frame
and find patterns
last time remember the nine dot problem
right and that these patterns
aren't just patterns in your mind
they're patterns and how knowing how to
make sense of things
so you're rock climbing and if that
breaks down
you impass you're stuck and i don't mean
just cognitively you're physically stuck
now if you want to be a good rock
climber what you have to do is you have
to break
that framing you have to train yourself
to break the frame
restructure change what you're finding
relevant and salient
and then change yourself to fit that
and then you refit yourself to the rock
face
you refit yourself to the rock face
then you have to do it again and then
you have to do it again
and then you have to do it again or the
jazz musician the jazz musician is
playing
they pick up on a pattern they play with
it but they can't stay with it too long
what do they have to do they have to
shift they have to restructure
they have to shift into a new pattern
and then play with that but they can't
stay with it too long they have to pick
up on it they have to refresh
again and again and again and again and
again do you see
what's going on with
the rock climber the jazz musician the
martial artist
is this idea of a cascade of insights
you're having an insight that's leading
to another insight
that's leading to another insight right
it's priming
so you know when you have like an
insight you have like aha
and you get that sort of burst of energy
and it's like a flash that's why we put
a light bulb over somebody's head
when we want to show them having an
insight it's like that flash now imagine
if i took that aha
and i extended it
[Applause]
that's the flow state it's an insight
cascade
so the more you flow the more you're
training your ability
for insight in
direct interacting with your environment
now the trouble of course with the video
game is you though the environment isn't
a real world
but in the shaman's world of course the
shamans flowing in the real world
the real social world the real
ecological world
but there's something more it's not just
an inside cascade that's going on in
flow that
that in and of itself would be great
there's something else going
this has to do with your capacity for
implicit learning
now notice what's happening here notice
that although even i'm doing
the history i'm always also doing the
cog sci
because while i'll be emphasizing the
history the historical account
i'm starting to build what i need to
give you the structural functional
account
okay so implicit learning this goes back
to work done in the 60s by arthur rieber
and a whole bunch of other
people so what rieber was doing is
he was originally trying to understand
how people learn language what he was
doing was he was
generating an arbitrary set of rules
completely arbitrary just
make them up on the spot set of rules
for how you can link strings of letters
and or numbers together like the rule
might be
you can't have more than three vowels in
a row or you have to have two consonants
and then you generate you generate
letter strings
eight nine long these are so long that
you can't sort of easily hold them in
your working memory
and then this is what you do you take
you generate
you can generate an indefinite number
you generate a huge number of these
strings
and you just show them to people here's
one here's one here's one
here's one here's one here's one okay
that's the first part of the experiment
then you do the second part of the
experiment now you generate
a whole bunch of strings but two kinds
one set of strings is generated by that
artificial
set of rules and so follows the same
rules as the first string
first set and then the second set is
generated by a completely different set
of rules
okay and what you do is you mix up
the first and the second together and
this is the task you give people
can you tell me the strings that belong
with the strings you saw before
there you go now
reba originally thought what would
happen is people would
because it seems like so random what he
found
was people score well well above chance
consistently on this people can tell you
oh no those strings yeah those belong
with the old ones
no that one doesn't that one does that
one doesn't now here's what's
interesting
you now ask people why how do you know
that
and they'll give you one of two answers
they'll say i don't know
i don't know i just i just feel it
which is or they
say they give you some explanation
they'll give you some rule or procedure
they're using
and here's what we know they're
deceiving themselves or
lying to you because that rule that
they're using wouldn't actually predict
their success
so you are picking up you have this
tremendous capacity
outside your conscious awareness
right to pick up on very complex
patterns in your environment
and you say okay why what does this have
to do with shamanism well hang on
because we talked about
the shaman picking up on patterns last
time
let's go back to this let me talk about
an experiment that's really interesting
so
there was some work done on this idea
you know the people have psychic
abilities and there's the feeling of
being stared at the
people can tell when they're being
stared at people reliably report that
they think
oh i knew somebody was staring i could
just feel it in the back of my neck and
stuff like that
and so they ran an experiment in which
they did the following they'd have
somebody in a room
blindfolded earplugged they can't sense
anything nobody's allowed to wear
perfumes or anything
that person can't see or hear or feel
and they're just standing in the room
unbeknownst to that person and then
people would come in and stare at them
and then they had to report if
the person at the center of the room had
to report if they were being stared at
or not
and people were reporting this well
above chance they were saying
i think i'm being stared at and there
was somebody there
and of course first of all right
but then it turned out
that if you made a slight change to that
experiment it wouldn't replicate so what
was going on
you bring people into the room
and they say i think i'm being stared at
and the researchers would tell them if
they were correct or not
they would say you're right or you're
wrong
so what you say so what well here's the
thing
the researchers thought they were
introducing
people the viewers into the room
randomly
but it turns out they weren't
introducing them randomly because you
know what's very
hard for you to do random stuff they
were actually
introducing people as viewers
in a complex pattern and the person
that was blindfolded and earplugged was
implicitly learning the pattern
because they were getting feedback if
you take the feedback away if you don't
tell them whenever they say i'm being
stared at or not if you don't tell them
they're right or wrong
their performance drops to chance
see a lot of what looks like psychic
abilities are your ability to pick up
implicitly on complex patterns in the
environment
without being aware of it
so hogarth in his book on educating
intuition
made a really really cool really cool
claim
makes a very good argument in fact i
think for this he says
that what we call intuition is a real
thing
but there isn't anything sort of magical
about it in the like the psychics
say or something like that your
intuition is the result of your implicit
learning
you pick up on all kinds of complex
patterns not knowing how you have done
that
but you get an ability to detect
patterns and you don't know how
that's why your intuition feels the way
it does you just sort of know
like you know things you're doing it all
the time to use a famous example from
dreyfus
you know how far to stand from somebody
and what angle to like where you should
stand how close you should stand what
angle you should stand
how as the conversation or the context
changes you're allowed to move closer or
farther away what angles you're allowed
to be at
but if i were to ask you to tell me how
you do that
you wouldn't know you would just say i
know how to do it
and yet when people don't know how to do
it it creeps you out
it creeps you out
okay so intuition now
hogarth points out
and this is something very common right
hogarth points out that you know
we have two different terms and we don't
realize we're talking about the same
thing
we have intuition when we think it's
going well
that implicit learning but we also have
bias
and prejudice for when we think that
implicit learning goes bad
the bigot has got intuitions
about races that are wrong
now why is how is it that implicit
learning goes
wrong well here's the thing
you have some complex pattern in the
environment right
and your implicit learning picks up on
it
the problem is there's two kinds of
patterns in your environment
there's correlations there's coral agent
patterns and causal patterns so what do
i mean by that
correlations is what any two things are
related to each other
so let me give you an example of a
couple of correlations that you
shouldn't confuse with causation
there is a correlation between how large
your wedding is
and how long your marriage will last
if you have a bigger wedding your
marriage will last longer
now you would be a fool to therefore
think you should have the biggest
possible wedding
because the reason why bigger weddings
predict longer marriages is not because
bigger weddings cause longer marriages
is because right they're only correlated
it's because bigger weddings reflect
a bigger social network more financial
resources
and having a bigger social network for
the couple having more financial
resources
actually does cause a marriage to last
longer
here's another one so i'm old enough
right and i was brought up in a
religious household that
i was you know when prayer was taken out
of the schools
and of course um people were very upset
about that
taking look at crime is going up as
we've taken prayer out of the schools
and things like that
by the way crime hasn't been going up
read some of stephen pinker's work
but let's say it was that's only a
correlation because here's another
correlation
we know that greenhouse gases have been
going up
steadily and that's part of the
environmental crisis we're going to talk
about
you know what has been also consistently
going down for the exact same time
period
caribbean piracy having pirates in the
caribbean and wooden ships with cannons
and stuff
as that went down greenhouse gases went
up
now i hope none of you think that we
could solve
global warming by bringing back piracy
okay so there are many things that there
are many
patterns in the world that are illusory
because they're only correlational
they're not causal see the biget has
picked up
on correlational patterns not causal
patterns
so what you want to do is you want to
train
your implicit learning to pick up
on the causal patterns that are real
rather than the correlational patterns
that are illusory now here's what you
can't do you can't tell people
to look for patterns explicitly go back
to reeber's experiment
if you put people into that experiment
where they're looking at the letter
strings and you tell them explicitly
what they're supposed to do
try and figure out the rules consciously
deliberately try to figure out the rules
their performance doesn't get better it
gets worse
okay and hogarth notes this in his
book on educating intuition we can't
replace implicit learning with explicit
learning because it is
precisely by being implicit that it
works so well
what can we do explicitly then what we
can do
is set up the right context the right
environmental factors
so that my implicit learning machine
will tend
more likely to get onto causal patterns
rather than correlational patterns
so i'll get good intuition rather than
bad intuition
how do you do that well hogar says
the way you would do this is the way you
do science you want to control the
context
right because what science is and you
know there's a lot of
science look science is a way of
distinguishing causal patterns from
correlational patterns
you set up an environmental situation so
that you can
distinguish the causal patterns from the
correlational patterns
what do you do well in an experiment
first of all
i make sure that everything is
very clearly measured i get very clear
information
very clear information i make sure
i'm looking to see that right that the
change in one variable
is closely followed by a change in
another variable so
i change your drug dosage do your
symptoms get better
right so i look for clear information i
look for clear feedback
and in science failure matters you test
the hypothesis
and disconfirmation has to be possible
failure matters now notice this
what hogar says is well what i want to
do is i want to i want to put you into
an implicit learning situation
where you get clear feedback like you do
in science
where there is a tight coupling between
what you do and how the environment
responds
and where error really matters like in
science
and he says what we should do is we
should try and do implicit learning
in those kinds of contexts
well here's what myself and my
colleagues argued
those three criteria that will turn your
intuition into good
implicit learning are exactly the
conditions for flow
clear information tightly coupled
feedback
and error matters the rock climber
is looking for needs clear information
tightly coupled feedback and error
really matters
that context really means
that there's a much greater chance that
their implicit learning machinery is
going to pick up on causal patterns
rather than correlational ones
so notice what we've got going on here
the shaman is getting into the flow
state
he's developing all these techniques for
getting into this deeply
immersive
flow state
and they're getting an insight cascade
and they're also getting enhanced
implicit learning picking up very
complex
real complex patterns
now this is intuitive they don't know
how they're doing it
now here's what's interesting too these
two
are reinforcing each other because the
insight
gets your cognition to explore for new
patterns
and then the implicit learning picks up
those new patterns
and then those new patterns enhance your
ability to restructure
and then right you keep exploring for
new patterns
acquiring the new patterns for implicit
learning and you keep
ratcheting your skills up getting into
the flow
state is deeply deeply enhancing of your
cognition
somebody who's an expert at getting into
the flow state
is going to be an individual you want to
have around now that individual is going
to have some
really serious challenges facing them
they don't know how they're getting a
lot of the information they're getting
they don't know why they're so
insightful they don't and they're
experiencing this radical at one minute
with the world
this loss of sense of self when they're
enacting the animal
right you have to understand these
insights aren't verbal insights
like in the nine dot problem it's not
words it's not beliefs
getting an insight in how the deer moves
it's getting an insight an
intuitive insight in how to talk to this
person to trigger the placebo effect
to help them to heal right now
so getting into the flow state
notice what's going on here notice
you're getting something that's
almost like a mystical experience it's a
powerful altered
state of consciousness it's enhancing
your cognitive processing
and the shaman is making meaning they're
singing they're dancing
they're telling stories they're altering
people's sense of what matters
they're altering people's sense of
identity they're healing and
transforming
people